had a company called by any means it was
actually J Cole's first manager
um and we ended up connecting with Kevin
Lyles at kwl and kind of just forming
like we were their creative team more or
less when they had Sean Trey that's when
300 came in so you know early Migos at
that time early Young Thug at that time
and we were just all on Park Ave with
[__] Kev lior and Todd just like he's
doing the crazy what the [__] are we
doing here type [__] leor sat across
from me in a desk that's like this wow
like not in a cubicle that's [__]
fire and he would just ask me the most
intimidating questions all the time with
no context why should I know you I don't
know I feel like he could say anything
and he's intimidating he's an
intimidating guy for sure really really
nice guy though but he's intimidating as
[__] I'm real tight with his uh brother
Maddie but um I've never met lior but I
just watch all his interviews and I'm
like this dude I heard he's really tall
yes and he just seems like he's just he
speaks like a Russian hitman yeah and he
just leaves with like every every
question is odd to start to meet
somebody with why do I need to know you
and you're like a 19 20 year old kid
like I you know what you don't need to
I'ma just go home you guys you don't
need to know me bro you're rich like I
mean but no that but that speaks to kind
of why I think lior amongst a million
other things has been so successful in
his business I was just some random kid
that was doing [__] and he was like yo
what that wasn't uh try to [__] on me
question that was to try to get to know
me here's your opportunity to tell me
what you guys can do and no I didn't say
I just want to go home I showed him uh
stuff we were doing for
the smaller artist on 300 of like social
clips and like right we built was this
the Mike's dead era of 300 no it was uh
this kid from God he's from Washington
not DC like state
I forgot his name but we were doing a
lot of stuff yes this guy named
Macklemore Travis Thompson um shout out
to Travis so yeah it was that's like was
the early stuff before like palooza and
the Pod hit and everything and I'm sorry
if I bore people no I never think people
want to know that you have like a real
real I feel like not a lot like maybe
people were just you know a lot of
people see your guys as clips and they
don't really necessarily dive all the
way in because you guys have like two or
three hour long episodes yeah
um so you have like real roots in the
music industry but in both sides too
like I did the label [__] I did the
creative [__] I did the independent [__]
like I've I've kind of had every single
aspect of the music industry which I I'm
happy about and then you guys obviously
created a dope brand uh Henny palooza
which toured I mean for forever
yeah yeah do say blue is it do say
paloozing hours is it still a thing it's
not a thing no okay it's done I don't
know if I'm officially allowed to say
that but we're not we're not coming back
it's over yeah sorry if I we didn't have
like more of a
a whole closing type thing but yeah we
ended at the Barclays
um seriously Jokes Aside was a huge part
of that and then also after Kobe like we
all got kind of old like that [__]
becomes exhausting when you're traveling
around the world drinking yeah like a
lot yeah um yeah it becomes really
really tiring so I mean it was an ERA it
was an incredible thing I think it's in
the lineage of
parties within the culture like I I
think it's up there in no way am I like
saying we're the tunnel but for our era
like that's a staple for our era as far
as what was going on in hip-hop at the
time with parties and I think we changed
how parties are now like the day party
is the thing now the Branded party is
the thing right the club the clubs are
are you know have been dying I think
they're trying to make a comeback with
these these new set of kids yeah I just
opened a club in Scottsdale and it's
like uh it's been [__] great it's
been amazing but you know we've been
lucky we kind of feel there was no
hip-hop clubs up in AZ so we opened the
spot and
open it right before Super Bowl whatever
happened to that Rapper Juice from he
goes by Richie Evans now he was really
dope still was dope Richie's dope he's
um
OG mugs my boy OG mugs manages him who's
like Tech Nine security and E40 security
and uh he just he just performed at
garyvee's v-con
okay
a little different than Black Wall
Street but yeah he goes by Richie Evans
now he was dope I always like juice a
lot juice was dope yeah the black wasp
and then we had hot rod
who was assigned a G-Unit and then we
had Willie North Pole who was signed a
ludicrous I remember Willie North Pole
and of course I remember hot rod hot rod
had a record with Mary J he did be easy
and you know the thing about Hot Rod is
he still lives in Arizona he's kind of
like a social media like he runs some
funny pages and stuff shout out to him I
think his shit's good times Jackson on
Instagram but he was really from
Sacramento so Arizona really never uh
embraced him like that because he was he
was from Sacramento okay well he I mean
but we we all thought he was rep Daisy
that was a weird time in in G-Unit
super weird that was like when you could
you could tell it was like
you know I remember when I was super
excited that MLP and MOB deep were on
G-Unit
money blood money was a decent album
there was no singles on there
um
MLP never dropped an album on G-Unit did
they not that I remember no but I I
thought even in my young naive time at
that when they signed mob deep I love
Mobb Deep and I didn't think it was over
from Mob deep I just thought it was
weird that Jeanette was signing acts
older than them and I was like this is
odd the MLP signing and love MLP
Warriors is one of my favorite albums I
[__] love MLP
I just I was like this is cool like
shout out to I as a kid I wasn't
thinking to myself like why is 50
signing guys that are older than him and
underground is fun yeah I was just like
this is lit like I didn't think anybody
was liked MLP but me you know what I'm
saying like I just figured it was all
some petty [__] behind the scenes
because wasn't MLP on Rockefeller yeah
then I think yes and then there was
something there was some other G Unit
Petty beef that he also signed that
makes a lot of sense there was something
[__] you hoe I'm signing an MLP By the
Way That You Don't Know Remix the only
version of the song I prefer yeah I
agree blueprint too you know what I mean
I'm glad this is the only podcast I can
have juice conversations on this is why
sorry I didn't come with my regular
press run [__] I just want to talk about
juice from Arizona Richie Evans
um